[Musique]
je viens de commencer à goûter la
liberté je dois manger 24 mois j'ai pas
envie de re tournoi absent tu crois
qu'ils ont passés dans une fréquentation
soit récession des fois c'est plus un
pied chez moi je suis chez moi ici
question grossesse passer les bosses sa
route vers le bas jean beauchesne de
tendance
ce que je veux a besoin du bar pour une
forêt va se passer ni soir les miracles
ni foot oublie quand et où celui ci sera
sociale je vais m'occuper de leur sort
et c'est moi qui mets tous les
financements ont fait 50 56 à du gras
savoye et nuit les clubs
takuji d'autres choses notre mouvement
apicale je sais faire que ça
le départ sur le barclays sur les
papiers les à montfrin comps pompe en
france sont des cons fait de l'argent
sur la plage ans pose des questions je
supporte plus de ne pas reconduire son
contrat
tu te rends compte de ce que ça veut
dire que tu le renvoi en taule ça veut
dire que tu me [ __ ] dans la merde
bientôt tu va me prendre pour ton papa
qui durera vingt piges
tu te relèves et encore
et en comptant sur une chanson vous
allez tous boire la tasse d'un petit
cran